yeah yeah it's wonderful that we can now
instantly snap great photos and save
them forever but why doesn't anyone talk
about where all those photos go the
thousands and thousands of photos I've
scattered across my old computers phones
and cloud services make me want to rip
my hair out and looking for a specific
one forget it but here's the exciting
news the biggest names in tech want to
help me clean up the mess
oh yeah and you too Apple's photos and
now Google's photos which was just
released last week want to put all of
our photos in the cloud make them easier
to find and make them look better so
which one should you go with well that
really depends on what devices you own
and how much you're willing to spend on
cloud storage the first thing these
services do better than most is help you
suck up the thousands of photos you've
collected and then organize them both
let you automatically copy photos from
specific folders hard drives even
cameras overall I preferred Apple's Mac
app for uploading since I could see the
progress of my photos
Google's uploaders for mac and windows
just tell you they're working you have
to go to the website to see your shops
on the iPhone and Android though I
preferred Google's app for easy viewing
and uploading next to that Apple's
iPhone app feels disorganized and
outdated and since both of these
services store your photos in the cloud
not on your phone or computer Google has
the real edge on pricing
- Google offers free unlimited storage
for all your photos the catch it
compresses all the images and downsizes
shots over 16 megapixels if you're not
into that you can pay to store full res
images Google charges $10 a month for
one terabyte for the same fee Apple only
gives you half that and Apple has no
free unlimited offering but the killer
feature is search Apple lets you search
by year location or keywords and by
person if you turn on the facial
recognition and assign a name to each
face Google doesn't yet let you search
by a person's name but it's way better
at facial recognition it even knew this
old photo was of my mom and that's just
the start you can search your photos by
keyword with
and we're tagging a photo caliper brings
up photos of my puppy though so does a
search for a Labradoodle
either way the whole thing is crazy fun
another thing that services do is help
your photos look better
both provide basic filters and tools on
mobile an apple provides more advanced
editing tools in its Mac app but Google
goes beyond editing with automatic photo
tricks I'm addicted to seeing what gifs
it's made for my clusters of photos it
also creates collages and quick videos
and you can make your own between those
perks the pricing the search I'm going
with Google photos I've just had an
awesome time using the service and
rediscovering old photos that said I'll
understand if Mac owners with iPhones
and iCloud accounts want to go with
Apple photos whichever you pick you'll
know exactly where all your photos are
at all times